it's not good no no it's really
disappointing
they haven't changed their recipes since
the soviet times and it
shows what is that why is that taste
very underwhelming communism
i'm excited about this um i'm terrified
are you but i'm confident uh i'm also
quietly confident that
i'm gonna win see how it goes
oh okay
things are about to happen i know just
guess what this is
a russian spirit what could it possibly
be
vodka oh my god ding ding ding ding ding
ding
the bottle though this is why i mean
that already on the look of it is
yeah this is like i don't have a i don't
have a problem with alcohol i'm just an
elegant lady
[Laughter]
tell me about your experiences with
vodka there's just always what are they
what are those spirits that really
show up and that's the one for me oh
crazy keep those cameras rolling
what's your experience if not again so
you do shot it normally you
shot it you chase it and ideally it's
after a russian sauna called
banya so you're really really hot and
the vodka is ice cold and it's a
refreshing pickle it's a whole
experience i mean i'm here for the
pickle
combination
to be i genuinely have been
oh christ oh
that really link is on doesn't it it's
like one of those cartoons with the
tongue coming
it's like it's not one of the it's not
the worst i've ever had but
do you think it's a repeater you feel
that feeling coming out
yeah well that's it but then it's just
like kind of climbing here and then
yeah the fire is really coming up it's
really burning i would have loved to
pickle with it
i feel like that would have been a
really good chaser vodka straight into
uh
scotch whiskey this will be fun it's the
only way to do it
experience like a swirl cheers
yeah so it would normally be sipped
rather than shot okay
look i reckon definitely have a few
definitely have a few gulps of it though
to really you know get that full
experience but it really is a funny
experience i think you smell it
burning your eyes from the get-go
oh no no
it's just it's just not for me
okay first of all i can't taste anything
after vodka like as soon as it gets hit
starts burning my
eyes yeah i love a bunch of warnings
before you consume something you're like
don't smell it don't look at it don't
touch it but it's great
okay i'm gonna have to go personally
with the vodka
i just really love that bottle look it's
vodka
it's vodka for me oh okay how could i
ever betray my homeland
look at this thing it's always vodka
[Music]
right walkers i genuinely
have never had marmite and this cake
does it well i'm glad that you're having
it in a crisp form as your first one
just really like going all out i've
never actually had the marmite one so
they smell like beef
they do they smell like um they actually
smell a little bit like pork scratchings
they're really flavorful though yeah
yeah it's not them
gary lineker do you know who gallery
lineker is i know that he has a twitter
account
my favorite thing about him was um did
anyone see the glastonbury sign it said
gary linekershag's crisps
yeah he had to in the paper and deny
that he shags chris
[Laughter]
but the jury's out on which flavor right
oh my god that's so funny which which
crisp flavor would you shag i mean i
think i'd go for a what's it
oh yeah it's quite nice but yeah i think
i'd go for what's it yeah functional
and tasty okay this is those are called
ski
or sunflower seeds uh they are like they
are less of a food in russia they are
more of a lifestyle
so if you eat sandwich key that tells me
everything i need to know about you
this is something that you like this is
a like a grandma would do
and so you just sit in front of a tv and
you eat them and my
aunt and i'm not kidding is such a fan
of sammy scam it's you crack the
you crack the shell with your teeth and
then you eat what's inside she has
a groove in her front tooth from
cracking so many shells i'm not kidding
this 100 true i just woman on the front
as well she looks really inviting
a little babushka yeah she's like a
pedal she's like a drug lord yeah
coming to the dark side right how do we
eat
okay so you take one which is little
seed yeah and then what you do
is you put it in between your two front
teeth and you crack it
with the sharp sides on each and so that
goes against
yep and then that opens it and then you
get this one out
what you learn to do is do it all in one
swift motion
okay then you just eat what's inside and
it's nice and salty and delicious
they are quite tasty right and the thing
is that just looks hard work there's
thousands of them
right so the thing is you could buy them
without the shells they sell them with
other shelves but people still buy the
ones in the shelves because they like
the challenge
yes but yeah no not the snack to have if
you're hungry
it's a lifestyle that's harmless it's a
lifestyle choice walkers every step of
the way
again it's not a snap it's a lifestyle
excited ta-da
[Music]
okay okay oh wow
right okay sorry what's going on with
yours
let me tell you a couple of things this
is meant to be like a soup
you make uh at home called borsch
which is originally ukrainian and
ukrainians are very very adamant about
that
uh in russia we eat it anyway um and you
make
i've never seen it in a in a jar before
this is going to be interesting
interesting it's a beet soup it's very
very good
it's like it's got beets in it yeah so
that's why it's red so it's got loads of
bits loads of chunks
oh yeah oh chunky boy
okay so we've got a british staple which
is
a copper soup you've never had a cup of
soup before i had a cup of soup i don't
think i've ever had a cup pasta
it's just so handy isn't it see i like
efficiency and copper soup is so
efficient
it's minimal preparation the only thing
that freaks me out
is that like it was a sachet of powder
you just don't ask questions okay okay
okay cool cool you just do it you just
have it
[Music]
oh that's nice it is nice it's a lot
thicker than the last time i had it
i'm not gonna have any more it's like a
savory milkshake
i'm kind of here for that though i'm
into that it's just comforting the fact
that's in a mug as well it just feels
even more
yeah you're just like yeah you can have
a
baby
do you know what i'm talking about that
one picture of baby yoda anyone no one
okay yes stood outside the window
yeah he is actually holding a cup of
soup potato on like his favorite
[Laughter]
right shall we see for me already
i'm not yeah that is not me
okay it doesn't smell too bad i've never
had it from a jar before so
okay something just apart from the fact
that i think i just literally swallowed
a rock
not bad it also matches my outfit no my
my mouth can't really work that out
um it's not as bad as i thought it was
going to be
russia just
the texture and the texture of it i just
can't
work it out it's got a bit of a kick to
it i don't mind the flavor but the
texture for me is a no
for me it's the copper soup every day
the fact that it was a sachet of powder
is so terrifying to me and even though
that may have tasted better the fact
that i can like deduce the origins of
what i'm seeing here
you understand what's in the bone it's
just more accessible
i'm gonna vote
okay okay
i i wish i could defend this but this is
so disgusting
it's called gimmick again and okay first
of all already sounds too medical i
think it is something that like
essentially
what is associated with it is that like
it's brown so
doctors and like your mom will be like
it's just like chocolate it has nothing
to do with chocolate it's just brown
but it's meant to be like the healthier
option and something that like
in a hospital they'll give you in place
of chocolate or like if you're diabetic
they'll give it to you
it's so gross and it has like a grueling
texture
i'm really not i know
what i want in a snack but i'm intrigued
yeah so it's quite a fun
texture oh okay but i'm here for the
texture it does smell like toffee but it
looks really intense
it's like fudge it is fudge
i've got a lot of time for fudge it's
like dehydrated brownie batter
i'm quite surprisingly into that
are you serious oh my god we should move
to russia now i feel really ungrateful
for my childhood
sorry grandma oh boy
right so i really want to back this but
now after tasting that
you're just going to be a bit
underwhelmed okay that's a party
this is fun it's tasty it's got a lot of
textures going on
you're never bored coconut apricot do
you know what i mean
got a lot going on for it yeah
very little very little is needed to
excite me these days
it's like the back of my pantry that i
just kind of collected and clumped
together
for me personally i know i should be
back in the uk but
i really enjoyed that i really enjoyed
that as in would like to take it with me
um and i know i should be back in russia
but that is bringing back so many
memories of being lied to as a child
that i'm gonna back this little number
russia was the winner
oh my god what no that's not called a
big role it is now next to
any role you're a liar what's it called
a twinkie
what an awful word i get these on grindr
oh a twinkie
i like that they have the standard like
you know poop shape
it tastes delicious